russia is pushing ahead with the global
rollout of the sputnik v vaccine
the russian direct investment fund has
struck a deal to make 100 million doses
of the jab in china
cooperation will help increase
production capacities of sputnik v in
china
to provide the necessary amounts and
help partners in the country and
globally to fight the pandemic
china is one of the major production
hubs for sputnik v and we are ready for
increasing the scope of partnership with
local producers
to meet the rising demand for the
russian vaccine
those upcoming stocks will be enough to
vaccinate 50 million people with each
needing two doses
the russian jab has not yet been
approved for use in china but assuming
that happens the chinese manufacturer
will distribute it domestically
as well as abroad so far sputnik v has
been licensed in almost 60 countries
earlier i spoke with victor gao director
of the china national association of
international studies
he thinks moscow and beijing have plenty
to gain from working together on
vaccines
for china to help russia to produce the
vaccine and to introduce that to
the chinese consumers as well as markets
outside of
china will be a very important thing
china has one of the largest
manufacturing capacities in vaccines so
if we
uh use the uh formula
produced by the russian site for the
production of vaccine physically in
china it will be a win-win situation
i do not see any reason why this vaccine
should not be approved by the chinese
regulatory authorities
and i hope the chinese people will have
a choice if they
want to use one or two or three
chinese vaccines they will be able to do
that if they prefer
the sputnik vaccine they will have a
choice
to be made by themselves
you